[Music]
you might call this a modern cinderella
story
but in our story the glass sneakers
don't find one pair of feet to wear them
happily ever after
instead they become assets which retain
their value over time
this modern retelling is all about
reselling
there's no prince in this story but
there are some very handsome prophets
bestiar collective is a luxury resale
company whose story began in 2009 when a
group of chic parisians decided to clean
out their closets and sell on what they
weren't wearing anymore
now the fashion resale market is booming
and earlier this year vestia collective
achieved a valuation of 1.7 billion
dollars in its latest round of funding
but this is not the only resale success
story
resale companies on both sides of the
atlantic are attracting investors with
the promise of new growth from old
clothes
and between vestir's buyers and sellers
is this the authentication center and
it's never been busier the whole year of
2020 we've seen 100 growth on items
being listed just thinking about the
sheer scale of unused inventory is just
enormous
it's time to examine the unstoppable
rise of fashion resale
[Music]
what we wear says a lot about who we are
yet fashion is also a 2.5 trillion
dollar global industry that touches
everyone on earth
i'm imran ahmed i first started trying
to make sense of the fashion business 15
years ago as it was being transformed by
technology
and shifting consumer values
now i'm on a journey to see how fashion
is recalibrating amid the pandemic
to balance profit with purpose
this is the business of fashion show
join me to discover how fashion shapes
business culture and identity
and to meet the people forging fashion's
future
old is the new new
while style setters have long embraced
the chicest vintage clothes
and savvy shoppers search thrift and
secondhand stores on the promise of
originality and self-expression
online resale platforms are facilitating
a bona fide buy sell buy sell
boom
luxury brands thrive on strict control
of distribution
price and perception
yet some are now embracing resale to
recruit new customers and deepen
engagement with existing ones
right across the resale market the
simplicity of transactions combined with
shifting customer values means second
hand is taking up more space in fashion
closets now
and in the future
as more and more of what we love to wear
is pre-loved
and the sellers
in the u.s alone it is estimated that 9
billion items of clothing are left
unworn
according to bof insights second-hand
fashion sales in the united states could
top 67 billion dollars by 2025.
buyers are first and foremost seeking
value for items for which they would not
be prepared to pay full price
while sustainability ranks only third as
a reason to purchase resale
sellers and investors cite support of
circularity
and the eco-credit of reducing emissions
energy and water use
but should we really be celebrating this
as slow fashion
or is it just another quick fix
could reselling unwanted items actually
be accelerating more first-hand
consumption
drops in limited edition products create
urgency and scarcity with some resale
prices more than six times higher than
retail prices
and how to be sure of real versus fake
in the buzzy youth segment how to
protect peer-to-peer teenage traders in
exposed online communities
resale platforms must be vigilant on
authenticity and safety
while customers on both sides of the
transaction should keep age-old mottos
in mind
caveat emptor caveat venditor let the
buyer and the seller beware
i'm on a train headed to leo a few hours
north of paris
it's here that vestire collective the
luxury resale company has set up its
authentication center to verify that the
products it sells are real
ceo max bittner showed me around
this whole area in turquoi yeah
was a massive part of the garment
industry which then obviously got hit
very hard with the whole outsourcing
right so the people here are super
passionate but they also really love
fashion it's really a fashion industry
so we can actually attract you know good
authenticators people who've been in the
industry
in 2019 max joined vestir collective as
ceo from lazada a southeast asian online
shopping portal acquired by alibaba
i mean the huge difference here with us
is
the senior authenticators and all the
authentics get three months training
okay which is very long
and what's the training that's provided
i mean we have the experts who've come
here whether they're from auction houses
or the like and you're speaking to one
of them in a second right
they basically go by brand by category
all the learnings that we've acquired
over the last 12 years
and with a lot of the brands we've
received also training from them
i'm in charge of the authentication this
is my seventh year at the collective i
come from fashion auctions
a counterfeiter will do always a mistake
and our job is to detect the mistake if
there is a mistake of course it's a
counter sheet
what's the most expensive
item ever sold on best your collector
the most expensive item ever sold was a
85 000 euro himalayan birkin which was
sold
from a hong kong seller to a new york
buyer
we actually had an incident two weeks
ago where someone bought a 250 000
golden patek philippe
but the seller then didn't strip it so
we were very sad about that but you know
they have been items close to 100 000
euros
bought and sold in the platform
the lower price point the minimum basket
size you can sell
is 15 euros so you can't sell anything
which is below 15 euros if you think
about the average basket size of sun and
some of these peer-to-peer platforms i
think that is their average basket size
so that we clearly differentiate there
and we try to limit
what i would call broadly fast fashion
uh we don't really want to have fast
fashion and encourage fast fashion on
the platform why not
we have a positioning of more higher end
fashion you know real luxury real
designer something that
people
you know want to buy and sell for a much
longer period one of the key things in
the roles that we play as a secondhand
platform is that we want to educate
people that what they buy and sell is
not consumables just fashion it's really
an asset and if you think about the way
we as a consumer class need to change
the way we think about
consumption is that we need to take much
better care and appreciate the value of
the items that we have because there is
a residual value
how do you respond to that kind of
criticism that you know the resale
market actually propagates consumption
as opposed to
manages it or minimizes it i think
that's is probably the question that
concerns us the most because i think you
know as part of our core mission it is
we want to change consumer behavior to
the better and we've actually spent
quite a lot of time with external
agencies to challenge ourselves
and and our goal is to be carbon neutral
by 25 without any offsetting and we've
looked through all our mission
whether it's our transport or the way
that we reduce consumption and we think
that target of being carbon neutral
without offsetting is possible
and fact of the matter is we do reduce
the amount people consume because what
we help them to do is to trade up
instead of buying zara firsthand they
buy cezanne second hand if buying
suzanne firsthand they buy isabelle on
second and instead of buying first ten
chanel they buy second hand ms so you
basically go up the food chain
and we want to hope and educate every
consumer that they should maybe pay a
bit more up front for an item that
they're going to wear longer and where
they're more likely to take care of it
and then resell it in the future but you
didn't come from this world
you maybe probably didn't even know what
a himalaya birkin was
i used to climb in the himalayas maybe
but i didn't i didn't find any burkins
there
no i i have to admit i'm i'm uh uh you
know i'm a brute yeah uh i think there
would be many people in the industry who
would probably still roll their eyes at
me and that's fine um you know i made my
career
selling six dollar dresses or 70 mobile
phones across indonesia and malaysia
it's a very different business but in
the end what we do is use technology to
connect buyers and sellers it's about
customer service about user experience
but the beautiful thing about the
products that we sell now and i've
really gained massive appreciation to it
is that it's real craftsmanship they're
real pieces of art
and trying to
educate people of that underlying
intrinsic value of these items and
therefore
making people change
towards what i think is better
consumption
i mean is probably the most fulfilling
uh thing there is how has con your
customer behavior both in terms of
sellers and buyers shifted over this
period of
disruption that we've all been living
through it's really allowed people to be
quite self-reflective
and and to start asking themselves okay
what can i do myself to be different and
secondhand is one of these very few
things where people can do something
today how do you manage that tension
around authenticity because without
authenticity
this luxury focused
operation you know starts to teeter a
bit if you step back on the the
actual topic of fakes at the moment one
in a thousand products is fake so the
chances of buying
something on mystier and it not being
authentic is one in a thousand is that
perfect no it's not perfect and we're by
no means
nearly done on on what we can do to
improve it coming back to the customers
we have this incredibly engaged
community and the beauty about second
hand is
that people really define their own
style they can you know shop
you know back
you know decades to find what they're
looking for they can find products that
they might not be able to look for i
mean we often you know think you know
the world is paris the world's london
world is new york but we have access to
people to products they would never get
access to
anywhere in the world so it's it's it's
really about this global digital
wardrobe
you know which gives access to to
products that people might not have
access to because they're too expensive
or because they just don't have a store
anywhere near them so it's it's it's i
just get really excited
um about it and i look at technology and
what it can provide it's it's just you
know it's
endless opportunity
the rise of resale now is akin to that
of e-commerce 20 years ago the field is
wide open the front runner has yet to
emerge no wonder it is attracting
billions of dollars of investment
it's a similar story of upswing over in
london
so we went to lille we visited with
westier collective to learn about the
luxury part of the resale market now
we're here
in the heart of east london to learn
about the mass end of the market we're
here to meet with depop
they are a technology company here and
they've had their own journey during the
pandemic and we're here to meet with
their ceo maria raga
depop is skewed towards lower price
products exchanged between younger
traders almost all of them 26 and under
and who are attracted to the community
aspect that a peer to peer platform can
offer
what makes
a community focused
platform like depop different from
typical
fashion e-commerce
from the very beginning um when you
think about the way the app has been
designed it has been designed with that
in mind it's not just a place where you
come to find an idea that you want it's
a place where you come to discover other
people doing other things
where you can actually interact with the
users and then you can also engage with
them in real life and so for us having
this community first appeal was
extremely extremely important
um from the very beginning and it has
translation into how we build the
product and also how we do marketing
there's a huge overlap of buyers and
sellers in the platform and that really
creates that sense of communities not
like a b2c uh model is it's really a uh
a peer-to-peer where people start as a
seller and then also become a buyer and
it's basically forces the sense of of
community but you know what about the
brands in your world do you have
engagement with those brands yeah so
we've been quite lucky actually because
we didn't have to go
out there and and talk to them they
actually came to us initially because
they wanted to
access to our community
they see as we see that gnc acts and
behaves in a completely different way
and so they wanted to collaborate with
us to understand that movement a bit
better
they also want to get more involved in
resale i mean and especially now that
has become much more prominent they are
trying to see what's their their place
there and so for us we we're super
welcoming because
we know that alone we're not going to
change um the world for better so we
need to work together how did the
pandemic impact
kind of supply on the on the platform
and
are there lessons you can learn
about how to get more and more people
aware that actually they have
assets
in their wardrobes
the pandemic made people realize that
they had a lot of things in their
closets
maria condo was also quite good on on
showing people that you've got
too much i think it was a moment in time
that made people realize wow you know
um
this is an issue on the back of that
there's obviously a lot more social
consumption so people are realizing that
you know there's far too much out there
um if you think about the amount of
items being produced on a yearly basis
100 billion it's crazy that's like what
more than 250 million items a day
um so it's i think people are starting
to realize um maybe up and then it had
to happen for people to notice that um
supply uh drove the demands because uh
people were listing all these items they
were talking about it in social media
and then people were coming to okay
let's see
um and so in terms of what we can learn
from that it's about
not mimicking what happened because you
don't want people to
be at home right so it's about
reducing the frictions that they found
along the way so like how do we make
sure that we connect with buyers and
sellers in a better way so that they
don't have to be looking at multiple
items so one of our core areas of work
right now is personalizing the app and
really making a big difference between
the browsing experience and the search
experience okay so while all of this
craziness
of the pandemic is going on
you announce
that you've been acquired
by etsy
what was it for 1.6 2 billion dollars so
basically two years ago um we met them
and uh yeah it was very much like a
knowledge sharing session and some of
the things that we ended up doing was on
the back of some of the conversations
that we have with them i realized that
first
they have a lot of there's a lot of
similarities in etsy and and depop in
terms of
values if you will so they really really
foster entrepreneurship and creativity
and they also really believe in in
consumers that are community-led
more than 2 million users joined the
d-pop community in 2020 proving the
rapid trajectory of the fashion resale
market
i met with fiona short and youth
two long time depop sellers
[Music]
youth how are you i've heard all about
you both have built their own businesses
to capitalize on this opportunity
now you're both in this market they're
calling the fashion
resale market and you guys are
d-pop sellers how do you define the
market within the community we don't
tend to use the word uh resellers for
ourselves because what we do is much
more than reselling it's curating
sometimes you're fixing pieces in fact
some of the pieces that we buy are dead
stock pieces and haven't even been sold
to a consumer before the term resellers
we kind of use more for you know the
drop culture so we just tend to call
ourselves um like vintage sellers or you
know vintage dealers yeah there's so
much to this
industry or whatever you want to call it
this community i feel like you can have
so many different interests and whatever
you do day to day whether it be
photography or styling or whether you
like hiking they always come through in
your vintage curation so even though we
do resell and that is a big part of it
and it keeps us going and it allows us
to carry on i think the main core part
of it is who we really are day to day
and what inspires us and our experiences
and where we come from and what we
really stand for okay so i have a little
challenge for you okay i bought this
t-shirt
it's the first thing i ever bought on
the internet wow okay like the first
piece of clothing i ever bought on the
internet i think i bought it in 1999 or
2000. would this have any value
if this was from like a concert or a
tour or something like this the price of
this would be a lot higher
so this is double stitching which means
it's made after 1992 but if it's single
stitch then it's before 90 90 which
means it's going to be worth a lot more
money can you show me the kind of stuff
that you guys sell
yes absolutely
explain to us why it's valuable this is
actually the very first piece um that i
picked up um from the markets in italy
um one euro one euro everybody
just
one euro
it's the john galliano top right yeah
you know it's just a total is it a
bathing suit it's a bathing suit
beachwear from the i believe it's from
the early 2000s um newspaper print
iconic john galliano and how much could
that sell for i mean
you know more about jungle leona but i
believe 110 maybe not maybe yeah yeah
all right youth what about you
i bought this at a market and it's a
betty boo versace
uh print which is one of their really
one of gianni versace's really what
color do you think this is from this is
like late 90s it's got a double stitch
in um there was one that was like early
90s which was like single stitching but
this is a later version but this like
has come back into like pop culture
through i think um it was a cardi b war
like an all-in-one versace with this
print and it's like
betty boop and i guess madonna so where
does this
market go from here
how do you see
the resale market developing and how
might that impact the way
you manage and run your own businesses
personally i see this already expanding
there's people who are starting in their
bedrooms selling their own clothes and
gradually now going into wholesaling as
the industry does get more saturated and
people do want to get involved in
different ways there are obviously
windows that are opening and doors are
opening yeah i think one of the things
that i like so much about this industry
is that it's based on independent
sellers individuals that are in their
bedroom you know the new thing isn't now
to get a paper round is to get you know
get you close and deep up and i think
that we're gonna see so many um young
young young people starting their
businesses and growing really fast i
think that um it's just gonna become
even more of a social norm because
remember like ten years ago wearing
secondhand clothes wasn't cool it was
counterculture but now as the coins
flipped and it's became mainstream
you know
fiona sold to belhadeed before you have
yeah what did she buy she bought two
really beautiful 90s vintage tops they
were really reasonably priced they were
beautiful they were just on the depop
available to everybody and i didn't even
know it was actually isabella and then
um i saw it on her instagram and i know
she was wearing it
she could get anything she wanted and
she actually sought
products out that she couldn't get
anywhere else that's really cool yeah
[Music]
well the most interesting thing for me
is that people are building
real businesses and livelihoods
on these platforms you know they've
created these whole new models of
interacting with customers in the next
10 15 20 years as consumers become more
comfortable
and these platforms grow in visibility i
think it's really going to transform the
way a lot of customers engage with the
fashion business
it's not going away the market is going
to grow
massively over the next 10 years there's
huge amounts of inventory sitting in all
of our closets just about getting that
inventory in circulation getting brands
to accept that this is a permanent
fixture of the market going forward and
increasing the visibility of these
platforms amongst customers
[Music]
you